hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control ia.l
2-3.5.8 prohibit password reuse for a
specified number of generations
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP Hunter 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got green news for
you you've found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it cmmc control
ia.l2-3.5.8 prohibit password reuse for
a specified number of generations no
we're not talking about your parents
we're talking about Generations okay so
on this one it's another great best
practice reminder that's really all this
is it's one thing to require users to
change their passwords but we also must
remember that users are creatures of
habit they will literally flip back and
forth between the same two passwords if
you let them ask me how I know so this
control mandates that we look at the
settings for how many generations of
passwords in other words how many times
can you use the same passwords in a row
to remember and make sure it's specified
and I recommend a little bit more than
just two or three passwords what this
prevents is a compromised password from
coming back into rotation and allowing
for attack so let's take into what the
assessors are really going to look for
and what they have to say on this one
all right two points of assessment here
determine if the number of generations
during which a password cannot be reused
is specified uh again we would say most
likely that this is implemented via
group policy or system policy of some
kind and then we might throw out a
number let's just say like 10 right uh
again you can't repeat the password for
at least 10 different Generations next
assessment Point determine if reusive
password is prohibited during the
specified number of generations
again here we would say this is
implemented via the group policy so
again Group Policy probably the easiest
way to do it you may have some other
configuration or setting depending upon
what system you're in but in this
example we'll just give the easy one
which is to say hey look at group policy
now if you're a defense contractor uh
and you have had this stuff dropped into
your lap like a seagull on a sunny day
the good news is at on-call we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins yes I want to show
you how to actually win more Defense
work all right and with higher profit
margins so important now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmc complianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance that
as soon as our compliancers roll it out
until the next compliance tip my friends
stay safe and secure out there and hit
us in the comments below to let us know
what you'd like to know more about when
it comes to information security and
compliance I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]